so every Disney cember I always find a
theme to tie all the videos together but
the downside of that is whenever I do
that a lot of other movies are released
and I'm not able to give them the Disney
zember treatment I mean don't get me
wrong Disney has had its hand in a lot
of things TV shows and movies and
animation of course but as they continue
to expand and keep buying properties it
seems like there's just so much Disney
coming out all at once so this year I'm
gonna make up for that this year it's by
popular demand that's right there's no
connecting themes there's no one studio
or one style of film we're looking at
all it has to do is have Disney's name
on there somewhere and be requested by a
lot of people you name it there'll be
animated films I haven't done yet Pixar
films I haven't done yet Disney Channel
movies Marvel films old and new even
films that just came out this year now
like before some of these I've discussed
before with my brother Rob on sibling
rivalry so if you want a longer review
of some of these movies and a different
point of view you can go and watch those
but I also like the idea of letting time
pass whether it be a lot or little and
seeing if they still have the same
impact as when I just saw them after all
the sibling rivalries are done right
after we've seen it so this allows me
some time to collect my thoughts even
more it is so cool just to see how much
bigger Disney is becoming I mean just
when you thought they couldn't get any
bigger
here they are owning all these different
properties and studios and for the most
part they're turning out pretty damn
good material but again we're here to
discuss what works and what doesn't
what's timeless and what's immediately
dated and on top of that what works as
being timeless or dated and what doesn't
work as being timeless or dated so if
there's ever a Disney movie Marvel movie
Disney Channel original movie Pixar film
or whatever I haven't gotten to this is
your chance to see if I finally catch up
with it sit back and enjoy this is
Disney cember by popular demand
you
[Music]